ja nicht nur energie wird knapp und
teuer sondern auch das eine oder andere
lebensmittel zum beispiel getreide auch
das ist eine folge des krieges viele
staaten sind auf lebensmittelimporte aus
der ukraine und aus russland eigentlich
angewiesen und schon jetzt ist die
situation alarmierend nach einem
aktuellen uno-bericht sind mehr als 190
millionen menschen akut vom hunger
bedroht das sind 40 millionen menschen
mehr als im letzten jahr das ist ein
großes thema heute in berlin beim six
seven gipfel dem treffen der großen
hilfsorganisationen und mit dabei ist
auch die welthungerhilfe und mit deren
generalsekretär mathias mogge kann ich
jetzt sprechen schönen guten morgen
mehr als 190 millionen menschen sind
akut vom hunger bedroht heißt das im
grunde dass eine weltweite hungersnot
unausweichlich ist
die hungersnot ist eigentlich schon da
und sie haben gerade die zahlen zitiert
aus dem jahr 20 21 in dem besagten
bericht wird ja schon einen ausblick
geworfen auf das jahr 2022
und da sieht es leider überhaupt nicht
besser aus weil da eben noch die effekte
der ukraine des ukraine krieg ist noch
dazu kommen dass wir müssen uns schon
darauf einstellen dass es eben zu
massiven engpässen kommt und dass die
zahl derjenigen die akut hungern eher
noch steigen wird welche regionen sind
denn da besonders betroffen eigentlich
ja das sind doch einige länder in afrika
da gehört der südsudan dazu die
demokratische kongo gehört dazu
äthiopien eigentlich das ganze raum of
africa gerade die unter einer massiven
dürre leiden also somalia äthiopien der
norden von kenia
der südsudan habe ich gerade schon
erwähnt aber auch länder wie jemen oder
pakistan gehören dazu jetzt haben sie
gesagt dass diese zahlen ja schon länger
auf dem tisch liegen ist jetzt noch
dramatischer wird wie bereiten sie sich
als welthungerhilfe darauf vor
ja gut wir sind natürlich genau in
diesen ländern als welthungerhilfe auch
tätig und versuchen den menschen
beizustehen indem man
nothilfe erstmal leistet wirklich den
akuten hunger direkt versucht zu
begegnen über nahrungsmittelhilfe über
die ausgabe aber auch von
bargeldzahlungen aber was eben jetzt
ganz ganz wichtig ist dass wir nicht nur
kurzfristig hier helfen sondern
möglichst auch versuchen die
landwirtschaft im land die
landwirtschaft in den kommunen
anzukurbeln und hier auch investitionen
haben in die ländliche infrastruktur in
märkten verbesserte straßen in
lagermöglichkeiten damit der hunger
letzten endes längerfristig strukturell
auch bekämpft wird wobei das ganz ganz
große probleme und das sagte er bericht
eben auch ist die ursache und das ist
meistens sind das meistens konflikte und
hier sind auch regierungen gefragt ist
sind auch die g7 staaten gefragt
friedensinitiativen nun
loszutreten
damit diese kriege sozusagen beendet
werden also entwicklungshilfe und
politische friedensinitiativen haben sie
genau das ist auch das was sie von
bundeskanzler scholz heute sozusagen
erwarten weil er wird ja auf dem treffen
der hilfsorganisationen
auch da seien
unbedingt aber es geht eben noch weiter
wenn wir uns das wirtschaftssystem
anschauen wenn wir uns das handelssystem
anschauen das ist nicht gerecht das ist
auch nicht zukunftsweisend das ist auch
nicht nachhaltig wir verbrauchen viel zu
viel natürliche ressourcen wir
verbrauchen viel zu viel nach wie vor
fossile energie unser handelssystem ist
eben nicht gerecht die armen länder der
welt kommen einfach nicht nach oben und
da müssen wir auch eben als g7 land
deutschland hat die rate hat die
präsidentschaft der g 7 in diesem jahr
deutschland muster vorangehen dann muss
der beispielhaft eben zeigen dass eine
andere politik und das andere
wirtschaftssysteme möglich sind dann
schauen wir noch mal auf eine konkrete
geschichte die bundesregierung hat jetzt
erklärt eine sogenannte getreide brücke
einzurichten damit ukrainisches getreide
jetzt zumindest mal aus der ukraine
rausgebracht werden kann in dieser
akuten kriegssituation für wie sinnvoll
halten sie solche aktion also das halte
ich für wesentlich sinnvoller als jetzt
zu versuchen in europa beziehungsweise
westeuropa und in deutschland noch
stärker sozusagen die getreideproduktion
nach oben zu drücken ich glaube es ist
durchaus sinnvoll den armen ländern die
eben auch auf getreide aus der ukraine
angewiesen sind hierbei zu helfen aber
was generell notwendig ist dass
allgemein die märkte für diese
getreideexporte import offen bleiben und
die länder sich nicht abschotten und das
passiert leider in verschiedenen ländern
das hier gehortet wird und dass eben
einige länder sagen nee wir lassen von
unserem getreide produzieren nichts mehr
raus sagt der generalsekretär der
welthungerhilfe mathias mogge vielen
dank für das gespräch und ihre zeit hat